joining me now is Pastor Corey Brooks
CEO of project Hood uh Pastor thanks so
much for being with us why do you think
the federal government feels the need to
to re-educate their
Administration you know we've had over
60 years of diversity training and
diversity all in the name of helping uh
black people so to speak um and what has
it done it hasn't helped us one bit it
hasn't helped us educate our children it
help it does diversity doesn't um create
jobs in our community it doesn't move us
out of poverty but what diversity
training does is it it enriches the the
the racial Essentials of those who are
enhancing themselves and benefiting from
those policies like the Biden
Administration is trying to do but at
the end of the day uh it does nothing to
uplift black people you know when you
say diversity doesn't help us in the
black community get jobs you know
there's this obviously diversity is can
be a virtue diversity of thought
diversity of background to any
organization but I think what we're
talking about I think what you're
talking about and I know what I'm
talking about is this formalized Dei
diversity equity and inclusion I got a
debate with with Dallas Mavericks owner
Mark cubin about this it's not simply
this this abstraction this feel-good
idea hey everyone should be included
it's an ideology that is taught and
apparently is cost $16 million to be
taught to federal employees yeah it's
it's this idea that somehow we can
create equal outcomes uh but what we
need in America is not equal outcomes we
need equal opportunities we need to
focus on true uplift that only comes
from hard work Family Values Merit and
good American principles those are the
things that uplift people uh on the
south side of Chicago where I'm from
that's what we're focusing on every
single day uh accountability
responsibility uplifting people giving
them the tools that are necessary uh for
them to live their lives but Dei is
doing nothing uh to uplift our community
yeah let's take a look uh Pastor The
Daily Caller is reporting on some of the
examples of the types of things that
were involved in this training quote
past government diversity trainings have
instructed federal workers that asking
an Asian colleague for help with a math
problem well that could be racist and
that men can of course become pregnant
now that's of course part for the course
in modern day Dei and that social pain
can be the same thing as physical pain
Pastor that's what we're learning within
the federal government yeah you know
what's so heart-wrenching is that
um instead of spending all this money
for to teach these principles I can
teach them real simple it's love your
neighbor as you love yourself it's treat
people the way you want to be treated
it's um it it's it's investing in all of
Americans making us the best that we can
possibly be and I think when we focus on
uh
practical um principles instead of
focusing on Force diversity and
inclusion that's the way we're going to
uplift the American society and that's
the way we're going to become a better
people so many times all we're doing is
facing uh focusing on this racial issue
these racial issues and it's not
bringing us together it's only U driving
us further apart yes the whole point is
to see past our superficial differences
to look into our internal character uh
Pastor Brooks great to hear from you
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else